foreign
Jay is with us in Boise Idaho Merry
Christmas Jay how are you
oh I'm well how are you better than we
deserve what's up
hey so earlier this month we were
rear-ended in a car accident and
thankfully no major hospitalizations or
injuries but the car is most likely to
be totaled
um we're now on day 19 waiting for
insurance to let us know wow but uh my
question my question for you is
um we bought the car in 2020 before it's
our BD before Dave Days days and uh we
ate on it
um it's worth um if they total it I
believe it's worth between 14 to 15 000.
um so we're thankful for that in the
market
um but we're gonna need to replace it
and I just want to know the wisest way
to do this uh we do not have the cash to
pay for a car and we
we just need advice yeah um
well it it
um you've been through a pretty
traumatic thing getting hit that hard is
a big deal
um and it kind of makes you think oh I
need to do this or that and uh you're
obviously trying to get out of debt
correct
correct we're we uh we had our um
our anger moment was was in October okay
and that's when we got intense and so
we're brand new on this we have our
we're we're in baby step two we have our
thousand dollar emergency fund how much
debt do you have other than the car
uh 30 on what
uh uh it's all consumer it's credit and
then the eight for the car is included
in that I'm sorry you set aside from the
car
it's about 20 a little over twenty
thousand and it's credit cards okay all
right cool
uh
well done yeah what's the process look
like with insurance right now so you
said that you've been waiting 19 days
what's their correspondence been like do
like are they in the process of
evaluating
well yes
um they are uh they I'm working with the
at fault insurance and um they are I
don't talk to them unless I call them
and um I think I've talked to her twice
but she the ball is rolling she said
they're waiting on um
uh uh estimates
um from your their uh their person and I
actually missed a phone call from I
think it was from her while I was on
hold for you so I think they're at the
process where they're ready to tell me
it's totaled uh or they're gonna fix it
we're in a rental car that they're
providing and the the day they total it
we have four days I am not in a hurry
I'm this is not we don't we are not in
panic mode we have family we have
friends we do not have to go buy a car
what's your other car within those
my vehicle is a four passenger it's a
Ford Focus our five passenger we have we
have seven in our family though
um so it's as far as being able to
um uh borrow a car we could do that in
the short term no I wouldn't know if you
had to for a little bit but until you
find a deal okay
um
this is going to sound bizarre so I'm
gonna go ahead and say that out loud but
it is also exactly what I have done and
what I would do if I were in your shoes
the goal here is not short-term comfort
the goal here is live like no one else
so that later you can live and give like
no one else so I'm going to use this
situation as an opportunity to pay cash
for a car with the equity that you get
out of this car so it sounds like
they're going to give you seven or eight
thousand dollars I'm gonna go buy a
seven eight thousand dollar car
okay
and that I got rid of your car note so
you just paid off a bunch of debt and
the the the only way you can do this
and fight through the emotions of what
I'm suggesting is to really tell
yourself the truth and the truth is this
is temporary
yes not that long okay so what's your
household income
75. so how quick do you pay off the
remaining 20 do you think
are are uh every dollar estimate is is
looks like it's going to be 23 months
that's too long
with what you make I was thinking about
10 months
so I think we need to cramp down on the
budget and uh maybe pick up some extra
income from somewhere uh maybe even look
for something else to sell but I want
you out of debt and about so that you're
buying a better car
with an up as an upgrade with cash by
this time next year is what I'm thinking
well I want to encourage you that for
for
fifteen thousand dollars if that car
gets totaled and you get that amount you
can still get a decent no no it's not he
owes eight right and if he gets 16. so
he's got that's going to be eight in his
pocket if he gets 15 it's gonna be seven
in his pocket so you can still get a
pretty good car for seven that's what I
want to do yeah literally before this
year I'd never bought a car over ten
thousand dollars and I've been driving
just fine guys
it's a long time for a long time simply
because I'm free but the point is you're
moving it's hard emotionally to move
with little kids down from a 15 000 car
to a seven thousand dollar car fourteen
thousand dollar car down to a seven
thousand dollar car but if you if you
remind yourself over and over and your
family that this is for a year temporary
this is an adventure it's a one-year
thing or a 14-month thing or a eight
month thing whatever it is when you can
lean in on this and get it done fast
then you can move up in car with cash
and so I can drive a junker for a period
of time well that's part of the
motivation too is you know to get it to
go from 23 months down to 10 is remember
that it's just a season and the more
aggressive you are the quicker That
season passes